So, that's how your immune system helps suppress cancer.
Problem is, it doesn't really support when you're trying to treat cancer.
If we had healthy cancer, nobody could get infections that could cause cancer.
But that's not the case.
And maybe that's one of the best things.
If we have a healthy immune system, there's a chance that I'm going to call the immune system.
It's going to be less.
It describes how cancer sells.
So, remember I said about toxicity.
It kind of changes the ability to detox things.
Actually, it's really important.
Because if we have a really good ability to detox things, then the chance of us being toxic
as it's survived will be toxic.
They're just trying to survive.
Because we're all emotional toxins.
Much like toxins.
It's just how toxic we are.
It really depends on our cells.
Bosure.
Over.
Just like another speaker said those things.
We'll let it survive.
So, you aren't going to bite.
Okay, we just don't want to worry about what you absorb.
Same thing, whether you eat it or just try it.
But you really, you are what you don't detox.
Even if you'd compromise the individual.
Let me say that before.
If you don't detox the virus, it's in your box.
It's going to cause a problem.
Whether it's an inert toxin, like a heavy metal toxin, or it's a biotoxin.
If you can't get rid of it, now a biotoxin won't go through the detox pathway.
So, there's three phases of immunity.
The immune system.
First of all, your immune system is trying to eliminate the cancer.
The immune system is trying to eliminate the cancer.
The immune system comes into balance with the cancer.
So, if you keep sitting at low and protecting this cancer,
you hear the living things.
That can cause cancer.
For the retroviruses.
20-year DNA viruses and things like that.
Right?
That person has cancer for 20 years.
40 years.
It's a huge nasty one.
It's because it could stay in that equilibrium phase for a long time.
Your immune system is kind of playing this tug-of-war carcinetic with it and keeping it at bay.
So, you have a decrease in the cancer.
So, the first one is the stomach destroyed.
It's eliminated.
Your immune system becomes volatile.
But in that...
This is normal.
Quengilizcie is causing a scar.
You get a scar.
They want that scar.
customic cancer.
patients get scar.
We stayed there for Federal
biotoxids are a major cause that must be a problem addressed because the cancer
actually starts to create a molecule for itself.
That keeps the immune system at high to the immune system is your gene regulation.
So it looks like it learns how to survive, that column of the immune response, so it starts
creating a molecule so when you reduce the immune system to kill off infection, we want
to get rid of that.
We don't want this constantly going on, so when it does its job, we need to calm down.
So it can actually change its environment, that's like going around, it's increasing,
so just kill impressive molecules, that would actually be good, right?
We need a sergeant that tells them to calm down, the immune system comes, part of our
immune system helps calm that down.
So it's really super technical, so that's important, especially when we get to what promotes
cancer.
The immune system can recognize and kill cancer cells, that's a new term that we call
immuno-surveillance, your immune system is very different than the cancer cells.
How does it tell a cancer cell to the lung cancer cell because of certain tumor specific
antigens?
No, but if a patient comes to me, you'll see a cancer, and that's why I lied to the specific
cancer.
The priority is to treat the cancer.
The technical stuff.
And we don't really need to know, but our immune system goes around and helps kill cancer cells.
So if I don't have a healthy immune system, it also secrete chemicals, cancer can grow.
That Jeff.
Remember what I said in the last conference?
Yes, it was here.
It was here.
That's where the dismantle of cancer is.
What is cancer?
It's the increase of cancer spread.
The blood vessels are cells, but the cancer cells are die, so it is occupied with oxygen, so
we can go into the rapid replication phase.
So this is a little aside, no, when we talk about nutrition phase.
So that is key.
We very kindly have the answer phase of the question to this.
So, the party did a lot on their home side.
The party did a lot on their home side.
Why did they go into the rapid replication phase?
In their green drinks?
In their green drinks, some of them say they're doing all these really great things.
And that's really great.
Why beneficial for me, why they wouldn't do a rapid replication phase?
Just find a high new system, okay?
It should still destroy the cancer because cancer is well juicing stress.
Certain antigens of their cell membrane.
So really good vegetables for you, right?
I have, why are they really good vegetables for you?
A couple of years ago, I said that there's a third reason why a person gets cancer's blood
as they have a suppressed immune system at some point in nitric oxide.
And I said that, so definition of cancer is really good for you if you're dealing with
heart disease.
It doesn't go through death.
And then it's for some reason it goes through rapid replication.
So it's reproducing.
We don't have to get into this discussion.
Cells, same DNA.
But doing green rags, especially things that are high in cancer, we should not be done with
cancer based.
Your immune system should recognize that as an increase in blood production in order for you
to get cancer.
Because the truth is, you want to do with heart disease.
Have a cell that aren't going through apoptosis, right?
And some that are going through rapid replication, either.
But heart disease has to be treated completely different from what somebody with, let's kill
cancer.
It comes to me, they have heart disease.
You don't have cancer.
But you still have to have some suppressed immune system, but it literally could be for a
week.
Then we have to treat it differently.
And I had to do this lecture.
All the way.
So, right.
Society, no.
Cale drinks, people were really made to be cancer.
Increased band effort.
Just kidding.
Cale's much higher than the fourth.
And maybe one of the more important things about your immune system is that it kills circulating
tumor cells.
And this is really important when you're talking about a person.